Thursday edition of PFT ot the last we
will see from Chris Sims in this setting
until we return from our three-week
hiatus for Chris it's three weeks and a
day because he doesn't work on Fridays
but that's fine
the 49ers worked as effectively as
anyone last season Chris getting to the
brink of a championship up ten points
with seven minutes left in Super Bowl 54
and then it all fell apart as we all
know by now so they go back to what
Dennis Green called the valley of zero
and zero and I think it's very important
to be realistic about what that means
and what it definitely means when we
look at the history of the past fifty
four Super Bowls when you lose that game
it is very difficult to get back to that
game and it's almost unprecedented to
get back and win that game the Dolphins
did it in Super Bowl seven the Patriots
did it in Super Bowl 53 one year after
they had lost to the Philadelphia Eagles
other than that it has not happened and
I say all of that because the 49ers had
a state of the franchise event yesterday
and Kyle Shannon said this I know we
were good enough to win the Super Bowl
last year and we didn't and that's
something we have to live with and
that's why the state of this franchise
right now is we've got to get back to
that moment we got to get right back to
that fourth quarter and get to have a
lead and we've got to finish the job and
the reason that I'm stunned by the fact
that he said that is because I have so
much respect for Kyle Shanahan he's one
of the great coaches in football right
now he's potentially going to be
remembered as one of the great coaches
of all time if he keeps doing it for
another 25 or 30 years the worst thing
you can do going into a season is set
unrealistic expectations and the worst
message you can send to your locker room
is we want to fast forward to the point
where it went off the rails for us last
year when you start thinking about that
moment and getting back to that moment I
guarantee you you're never going to get
back to that moment because everyone's
gunning for you this year Chris
everyone's coming after you you've got
to dig out of zero
one-zero in a division as the seahawks
the rams and the cardinals don't think
about what you're gonna do in Super Bowl
55 with 10 minutes left
think about what you got to do week 1
out of the gates you got to build the
house brick by brick to even have a
chance to play a playoff game much less
the Super Bowl so this to me when I saw
those quotes I was blown away because I
would expect it from Freddie kitchens I
would expect it from a lesser coach this
the last thing I expected from your good
friend Kyle Shanahan yeah well I can't
say that I said you're really can say I
would expect him to say that either
right I mean yeah even being my good
friend and knowing who he is
was I a little shocked that he said it
when I first saw it yeah okay I was but
the more I thought about it the more I
just go well this is my buddy this is
who he is he's confident and he does set
goals like that for himself and even
within saying broad statements like that
you know first off he's a different
coach than most he is he's a little bit
more honest he's wired a different way I
know he's extremely honest with his
players and his team and everything that
way and I think we're Kyle Shanahan it
could be different in this way to where
he can make a broad statement like that
is he's he's a you know he's a psycho
I've known him for a long long time any
coach that his coach for him would tell
you like woo you got to work for Kyle
he's tough he's demanding he is like
that every day so I think he can make
those type of comments because he knows
that he is going to challenge himself
and his team on a daily basis to get
better and better that way and he's
hoping it leads to that ultimate goal
yeah it's rare that you hear coaches
said he's stuff like that especially
established ones but you know I do go
back to his honesty you know and he
expects and drafts players like we've
talked about that it's pedal to the
metal Oh coach you want me to run
through the wall okay I won't even think
about it and we kind of saw and felt
that energy when we were there in San
Francisco for that divisional playoff
game I think you mean
Harrison were like whoa this is a
confident team like are they too
confident this is unbelievable and I
think that's a little bit of the
shanahan factor and one evaluating the
type of players and Tammany wants on his
team but - that's how he got he wants
his guys to think and that's how he
thinks and I think he's capable of doing
that without losing the day-to-day you
know details and you know what do I want
to say motivating factors to make that
day its best so you can ultimately reach
that that end goal so but I hear you
Mike I was a little surprised too during
the show today we were talking about
your quarterback rankings Patrick Holmes
at number one would we take mahomes of
the field for next year and one of the
reasons I went field is there's too much
unpredictability this season
there's too many factors the coronavirus
situation potentially will derail entire
franchises right so that's another
reason to not fall into this trap of
trying to will your way back to that
moment when you're up ten points with
seven minutes ago in the Superbowl there
are too many uncertainties there are too
many variables and I understand this was
a state of the franchise event and
there's a certain amount of
hip-hip-hooray that goes on right yeah
the team says some things too but you
know this is one of the things that
drives me crazy and every team does this
no matter how good or bad they are where
you want to win the Super Bowl this year
you can't define success by winning the
Super Bowl I know they all have to say
it to get their fans engaged and I think
that's what this is and that may be how
Kyle yeah into the trap because he's
expected to say something that's gonna
rally the fans and what rallies the fans
more than saying we're gonna get back to
where we were last year and this time
we're gonna deliver it's just a very
very dangerous bar to set when you are
in the best division in football when
everyone is going to be coming after you
when we have a quarterback who tore his
ACL in week three two years ago and
could do it again right right there's
already enough pressure on Jimmy
Garoppolo as it is true to create this
presumption they're gonna end up right
back where they were last year what if
they start off one in three you know I
remember the year after the Vikings went
15 and one and there was an anticipation
Chinn went they should have beaten the
Falcons in the NFC Championship game it
was just unfinished business and they'd
be fine and everything would be they
started off like 1 & 3 & 2 & 4 and it
was panic because everybody just
expected they're gonna be just what they
were last year and if we've learned
nothing about the NFL over the past
really 50 years you can't assume that
what happened last year is gonna happen
again
this year and I think it's more
important in the post free agency days
back in the 70s ya the steel is gonna be
great again what a shot in today's NFL
especially with this pandemic you cannot
assume that what happened last year is
gonna happen this year and I just I was
surprised and look and again the reason
I was so surprised is because I have so
much respect for Kyle Shanahan this
seems so out of character for him and he
probably regrets that he said it the way
he said it and he's gonna have to get
his players to think very differently
and I doubt that this is the message
he's gonna have all year long no no you
the hard part is getting back the the
hardest but that's what makes it so
cruel to the 49ers and their fan base
Chris the all the work was put in the
hay was in the bar and all the effort
was to get to a 10 point lead with seven
minutes left the easy part is finishing
the job so uh yeah I just look you give
me the 49ers of the field in the NFC to
get back to the Super Bowl oh I'm
definitely taking the field yeah I hear
you I mean I think that's you know a lot
of logical thoughts there's no doubt
about that you know I think yeah maybe
you know Kyle did get caught up in the
fanfare and the moment and things like
that I think like one thing is when they
get together as a football team at the
starting training camp he's gonna set
forth the goals and the things that need
to be done you know and he'll break it
down more into then there's we gotta get
back to the Super Bowl right I mean
that's what coaches do it's gonna be
about like getting better every day and
training camp then you know winning the
division and then if you don't win the
division you know getting to the
playoffs there'll be a set of goals
there that he will hopefully that he
hopes of all you know ultimately lead
his team to getting back to the Super
Bowl and finishing the job
now two other things one the early
season schedule does set them up I think
to be get that confidence going and
feeling good again you know again I
think we could sit here and go yes we
know the Cardinals are dangerous but I
just look at it and go I feel very
confident right now
in June of 2020 that the 49ers are
better than the Cardinals the Jets the
Giants and the Dolphins and those are
for two their first five games so they
could get off to a good start and you
know Mike the other thing we've talked
about I know you and I in this pandemic
year the 49ers are one of those teams
that didn't have a kind of changeover
you know they got a lot of the pieces
back and things like that to where I
don't think there has to be any of that
growing and then of course Shannon has
the ultimate confidence and his ability
to make things easy for his quarterback
in his offense to begin with to where I
do think they're one of the teams that
are set up you know to not be
necessarily as screwed up maybe as other
teams are by the lack of an offseason an
OTA and training camp so those are some
things in their favor but you like
you've said this is still this is a big
big obstacle to overcome when you lose a
Super Bowl traditionally you have Super
Bowl hangover and you don't play great
the next year yeah I mean look how
Shannon and Bill Belichick have a ton of
respect for each other and I know how
Bill Belichick would handle this what
happened last year does not matter it
does not matter nothing that happened
last year carries over this year none of
the wins and all the points none of the
anything that we did last year if
anything what we did last year makes it
harder to win this year because
everybody wants to beat us even more
this year than they did last year and
think about how close so many of those
games were think about what week 17 came
down to how easily could have gone the
other way and the 49ers would have been
the five seed going on the road in the
wild-card round versus going home and
getting a pair of games there that's
that's how narrow the gap is between
them and the Seahawks right now and then
you've got the Cardinals that are rising
you've got the Rams that are still
coached by Shaun McVeigh yeah and look
at that that's Saturday night game
against the Rams the rabbit they had to
pull out of the Hat twice yeah sure
long that they converted on the same
drive to different times it's a season
of 16 games is an extended collection of
moments and all it takes is one or two
of those moments to turn the other way
and and for the forty niners you're just
one you could pick six or seven
different moments you turn that one the
other way and they ain't in the Super
Bowl
forget about holding a ten-point lead
with seven minutes left they're not even
there so that that's uh and that's what
he's got to tell his team and you better
hope his team didn't see the comments
that he made last night cuz he's got to
put that toothpaste back in the tube and
he's got to get these guys to realize
this is a new house it's not built and
we got to start laying bricks today
Chris right so I think this this because
it's not a failure if they don't make it
to the Super Bowl this shouldn't be a
failure of a season he's trading a
scenario where if they don't win the
Super Bowl this year it's a failure it's
not a failure the the success is
creating a team that's gonna contend
every year for as long as Kyle's the
coach that's the good news you're not
gonna win it every year and don't expect
to win it every year anyway no I'm you
know Mike I agree with all you said you
know you know only thing I'll say just
to finish it off is he is a different
breed of a coach he is and he does you
know I don't think he's gonna he's
already breaking the molds and we don't
even know because I can't tell you all
the things he does that are cutting edge
behind the scenes for his team and
things like that to begin with but yeah
he's a little different mold of the Bill
Belichick old-school even Mike Shanahan
he would've never probably made a
comment like that or said anything like
that to and I don't think Kyle was
trying to make a prediction but yes was
caught up in a moment does have great
confidence in his team and himself and
all those things and probably was just
trying to fire up the fan base a little
bit but I hear you it's just very rare
you hear a coach say save those type of
things but he's a different kind of
coach I'll tell you that well we'll see
how it goes and we hope that that he
gets his first of many championship
rings sooner rather than later this
isn't a knock on the team it's just one
of those subtle
things about setting expectations and
getting your team in the right mindset
it's one of the things that Bill
Belichick lives by and I think Kyle
Shanna has got the chance to become
another Bill Belichick this is just one
of those things where you got to be
careful because it really does set a
tone that is unfortunate that is too
aspirational and impossible especially a
minute pandemic to have any real
confidence you're going to achieve all
right that's it for PFT ot that's it for
Chris Simms he's done he's gone until we
return in late July three weeks in one
day off for you but you know I will say
this I mentioned this earlier over the
next three weeks I get 15 days off you
only get 12 days off so I got a better
vacation than you do well how did that
work out why just because you mean the
my not because I yes for you you get 12
days off because you otherwise would
already have the other three you were
scared a second you thought I was
getting more time than you know but for
me I get it because I get Friday you
know right anyway now I've worked every
day since January 1 2004 every decade
bill no cable no days off no days off
okay we'll see it was pretty empty live
on Friday see it Chris yeah
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports